i'm gonna do well because this is my
demo you know people with body oil deals
uh that's what really relates to what i
talk about
people with 20 million dollar face cream
endorsements give it up for whitney for
doing this for all of us how cool is
that you know
this isn't weird at all you know it's
not like judy garland's last days
at all not at all this is you know
whitney hussein here walking around like
a psychopath
happy 911 too those were the good times
remember 9 11.
though you didn't know it then but that
was remember going on fridays
hugging people that was the [ __ ]
none of you care about 911. don't get
soft on that you didn't do
[ __ ] after 9 11. i love that whitney has
more of a budget than all of comedy
central
it's amazing like this is a better
production than a comedy central half
hour
the comedy center that i found right now
is just a guy taping you with his phone
literally this is such a tremendous
production oh delete just got here good
it's fun it's topical the point um
this is his crown though let's be honest
it's
an influence or heavy you know they
don't relate to these people
um whitney always ridicules the skin
things that i you know try
you know i have a deal with a a very
advanced
skin you know cream called cortisone
[Laughter]
with hello
and i always come over here and she
ridicules me and she gives me like you
know whatever bad semen
concoction is spent giving her thirty
thousand dollars to put in a [ __ ]
and i love this crowd because no one has
a job like do you realize that
no one in this crowd has a job the
disney channel girl had one but no one
else has a job like everyone else just
loafs around that everyone's job in this
crowd is to say hello to
20 million hello hi
what do you do for a living i say hi
i defend chrissy teigen um i'm kid i
don't think she's eating kids i don't
think she's but
yeah i don't i don't know but i don't
think she is she's not twitter too much
you know she doesn't have the time
but it takes work the sawing of the leg
i'm kidding many of you are like oh no
it's getting weird
this is so fun whitney's chloroforming
your dogs
you know
it's not a scam but you know you just
gotta has anyone had it here
has anyone had coveted here no one huh
not you with a hat no not one person
did you know any does anyone know anyone
that's had it
you knew someone that had it was it bad
no it was light
[Laughter]
was it long did they lose their sense of
smell
what a fun group to do crowd working
fun group here nobody can really respond
you know
everybody's in industry everyone has
crowds of part like a one person
industry they're like i don't
i don't know what this pig wants
[Laughter]
nobody knew what this was we still don't
this guy you see
you know you came that way to make
movies didn't you
you wanted to change the world now some
psychotic rich [ __ ] has got you filming
her friends at a basketball court
ain't that the way take the mask off
buddy and
let's go see jesus together all right
thanks so much everyone what a treat
give it up for whitney hussain cummings
[Applause]
who's next spade who's going up next
no one olivia martin who's doing it
who's here kesha is cashier gonna do
one-liners what if kesha just got up and
did racist one-liners
and murdered